the director your gosselin Thomas I mean
actually killer you've talked on the
show about doing sex scenes in how
embarrassing that can be with with your
Goss London boss no does he make them
less embarrassing more embarrassing more
awkward otter
he's very even me you have to feel safe
to be able to do those things that you
have to feel secure the director need to
trust them and I trust him completely
it was just all quite embarrassing yeah
but you were a special thing to protect
because Emma I thought Emma Stone yeah
she was worried about you
yeah well she was so Emirates Damon had
to finger me sort of avoid finding
anything that you shouldn't have because
it's sort of under the shoots like that
and she said a little bit worried about
it don't worry don't worry I'm will I
know I know so I asked makeup Titan if
they had a sponge and so I've got a
sponge there the fungus sponge it was a
big wet sponge you made up this story
afterwards
the picture just going up my leg and
shoo it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna use a sponge you will feel
something soft and wet don't worry
[Music]
you